kim kardashian and pete davidson are
more in love than ever before but a
source tells et why kanye west is still
bitter about their relationship you just
gotta roll with it yeah it seems kanye
might be taking that advice because our
source says the rapper's attempting to
accept that pete is here to stay kanye
will never fully give up on the idea of
getting back together with kim but he is
slowly understanding that it is getting
less and less realistic and that
torments him it's also a part of the
reason why he's been keeping himself out
of the spotlight we haven't heard much
from yay since january when he dropped a
diss track about pete called easy god
sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
but things are different for the grammy
winner now our source says quote kanye
is purposely laying low right now as he
knows he has gotten himself into enough
controversy and he is finally
recognizing that just do something for
my heart and as always kim and kanye are
putting their four kids north saint
chicago and some first at the end of the
day our source adds their co-parenting
routine is manageable and kim is doing
her best to make it work and i do have
you know a family that i have to just be
positive and get it together for and
from what we've heard pete is helping
manage those positive vibes our source
shares kim's kids think pete is so funny
playful and adore him he's just super
genuine and it's no surprise the snl
star is good with them he recently
opened up to kevin hart about wanting
little ones of his own my favorite thing
ever which i've yet to achieve is i want
to have a kid
that's like my dreams it would be so fun
to dress up a little dude like you know
like you saw it's just like i'm so
excited for like that chapter so like
that's kind of what i'm just preparing
for now is trying to be like as good as
a dude and develop and get better so
when that happens it's just easier our
source says kim and pete have spoken
about him wanting to be a dad but at
this moment they are focused on building
their relationship right now kim
supports pete by being attentive to him
checking on him and texting and
facetiming him when they're apart she
has her own ways of making him feel
special and she certainly makes her
presence known in his life pete is has
got to be literally the best human being
i've ever met like the best heart people
always say like oh he's so funny and
it's like has to do with how funny he is
that's like
fourth on my list of why i like him
[Music]
you